Professor Amy
Hungerford: Today I'm going
to talk about censorship in the
United States since 1945,
in the period that we're
studying, and I'm going to
connect that with The Human
Stain and some of my general
thoughts about Roth's work at
the very end of lecture.
So, I'll give you a little bit
of history and then a little bit
of meditation on Roth.
I asked you,
for today, to go around to the
various bookstores in New Haven,
choose one and go,
and observe what you saw there.
And in particular I asked you
to think about what you are not
seeing there.
So, does anyone want to tell me
what they saw on their little
observation trip?
What did you observe?
Yes.Student:
I went to Labyrinth,
and they had a ton of history,
historiography,
cultural studies,
all in the front,
that seemed very deliberately
diverse.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Diverse in what
way?Student:
Diverse,
culturally, as far as the
history books that I looked at.
They ranged anything from
Germany during the Weimar
Republic, to the history of
tragedy,
to death in the Atlantic slave
trade, to all sorts of other
things, though mainly European.
What was not there,
which I found interesting,
which I looked for
specifically,
because I thought it might not
be there, was Mein Kampf.
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Did you look
back in the stacks too?
Uh huh.Student:
Yeah, I looked in the
stacks.
I didn't see it there,
or in the library at all,
so I guess they don't support
Hitler,
which I approve
of.Professor Amy
Hungerford: You approve of
Mein Kampf not being in
Labyrinth bookstore.
Student:
I approve of not supporting
Hitler, I guess,
Mein Kampf…
Professor Amy
Hungerford: Very good.
Okay.
What else?
What else did people notice?
What did you notice about the
bookstore?
Yes.Student:
There is a table that has
works by Yale
graduates.Professor Amy
Hungerford: Which bookstore
did you go to?Student:
Barnes and Noble.
Yeah, so just clearly trying to
sell to the market they
know.Professor Amy
Hungerford: By Yale
graduates.
But here's a question:
not by Yale
professors?Student:
I'm not
sure.Professor Amy
Hungerford: It's a
significant difference.
What else did you notice?
Yes. Local market.
Someone--Yes,
Eli.Student:
I guess that I really
haven't thought about this this
much,
but how much of a decision it
is to decide what kind of shelf
the book goes in,
like history versus philosophy,
and I guess it's probably the
publishers who do that,
or, I don't know,
but--Professor Amy
Hungerford: Well,
this is a really important
question: where to shelve the
book.
Now, it's not just about
categories, although it is
partly about categories,
what subject matter does a book
belong to;
it's also about what kind of
shelf, physically.
So those tables that we're
thinking about in Labyrinth,
with that array of literature,
who chose that?
Does anyone know who chose that
literature to put on that table?
I can tell you in a minute.
One question is: who chose that?
Now, those tables are in Barnes
and Noble, too.
So, you walk into the bookstore
on the ground level,
and there are all those tables,
and the stacks go up really
high.
There are all these elaborate
ways of getting books' covers to
face you.
Okay.
Then there are all the stacks
and shelves up on the upper
level, and those books are
interspersed with smaller
displays.
So, if you go up there,
you'll begin to see some very
interesting things.
There's a little table,
for example,
up on the right.
Maybe you noticed this,
right as you come up the stairs
in Barnes and Noble,
and it's promoted as "urban
literature."
Well, in my experience,
having seen it over the years,
it's really just code for black
writers,
somehow, so it's all these
books about the black history of
New Haven, or whatever.
So, you have these little
tables around.
Now, the big tables in
front of Barnes and Noble,
who chooses what goes on there?
That space is bought and paid
for by publishers,
bought and paid for.
It's part of the contract with
the publisher to stock that book
that it be displayed in certain
ways.
You know those nice discounts
that you get,
20% off the New York Times
bestseller books when
they're in hardback?
Those are possible at Barnes
and Noble because of the huge
buying power of that bookstore.
So, they buy in huge volume.
Now, a store like Labyrinth or
its predecessor,
Book Haven, wasn't able to have
that kind of volume in sales,
and so they couldn't negotiate
with a publisher that sort of
discount.
So, that means that a smaller
bookstore, because of its
smaller buying power,
can't provide a competitive
price in a market where Barnes
and Noble is right next door.
Now, there were ways that
independent bookstores try to
compensate for that,
especially in this market,
by giving discounts to faculty
members stocking their books at
the bookstore.
This is somewhat controversial,
although it's Barnes and Noble
that has tried to make it
controversial by bringing it up
with the university and saying,
"Now, isn't this a kind of
bribery?"
But that's the way that a store
like Labyrinth,
or like Book Haven before it,
was able to try to be price
competitive among people it knew
wanted to buy from them,
those professors who stock
their book at an independent
bookstore.
So, back to this question
of who decides what's on the
table: at Labyrinth I went in,
and I said, "Who decides what's
on this table?"
And they said,
"Oh, she's over there," and I
went and talked to her and I
said, "How do you decide what's
on the table?"
She said, "Well,
you know, I had a good general
education as a young person,
and I kind of know who's who in
the intellectual circles in
Europe and in the United States.
And so I browse the lists,
and I talk to sales reps when
they come in,
and I read,
and I look at what certain
courses are stocking,
and I see what people are
reading on campus,
and then I decide."
That's really different from
that space being bought and paid
for by a publisher as part of a
marketing agreement.
Those tables are very powerful,
for browsers,
in shaping what browsers might
possibly buy,
or think about,
when they come in to a
bookstore.
So, that space is
particularly key to a
bookstore's presence,
culturally, in the community.
And Sarah's point,
about the Yale graduates on the
bookshelf: that is a nod to
Barnes and Noble's immediate
context.
So, there is that local
marketing piece.
But, think about this.
There are just a few fiction
buyers who work with publishers
to decide what novels will end
up in Barnes and Noble.
So, writers,
when they're thinking about,
"can I sell my book?"
instead of thinking,
"I wonder if I can impress the
owner of the Seminary Co-op in
Hyde Park in Chicago,"
--a very famous,
huge, wonderful bookstore,
not a chain--instead of saying,
"I want to sell my book in
Chicago.
It's set there,
and maybe it'll be appealing.
I wonder if I can impress the
owner of that bookstore," and
having a strategy that addresses
those kinds of individual
circumstances in different
spaces-- Powell's in Seattle,
Labyrinth in New York--they
have to say, "I wonder if I can
impress the buy from Barnes and
Noble."
So, instead of many people
making that decision about
whether a novel is worthy of
being promoted,
it's one person.
That person becomes extremely
powerful in shaping what
literary texts reach us,
what comes to our attention
through the bookstore.
Now, have you ever
wondered, as you're driving down
the street, why there might be a
Dunkin' Donuts here,
and a Dunkin' Donuts just two
blocks away?
Have you ever noticed that?
There are various stores that
you'll see this:
gas stations sometimes,
fast food restaurants,
sometimes Wal-Mart.
Bookstores are another that you
will sometimes see this.
Why is that?
Well, what they're doing is
competing in an overwhelming way
with another store in that
market.
Usually this happens when
they're trying to drive another
store out of business.
So, they're a big enough chain,
they can absorb losses from an
unproductive second store to
saturate a market,
and then they can absorb the
closing of that second store
once the competitor has been
driven out of business.
So that's why that market
saturation happens.
It's not because they think
it's going to be profitable,
that there's another
hundred-percent increase when
they add that second store one
block over.
It's all about market
saturation.
It's getting it as close to a
hundred percent as possible.
So, those kinds of tactics are
possible for chain stores,
and they are not possible for
independent bookstores.
And this is how many
independent bookstores have been
taken off the map in our cities
and in the suburbs.
So, this is one way that
censorship comes to us:
not in that old-fashioned way
of censorship laws,
but in a new way,
market censorship.
This has always been part of
how things work in a capitalist
economy.
It's true that in the past
literary enterprises--be they
selling books or writing books
or publishing books--had to make
a profit in order to stay
afloat.
But the way that profit was
made has changed from the early
twentieth century until this
point, and I'm going to say more
about that.
So, just by going in to the
bookstore, I want you to think
about--the next time you go in,
think about how things are
being presented to you.
Now, how many of you get most
of the books you buy--not for
classes…well,
let's just ask this,
blanket, and then I'll break it
down--how many of you get most
of the books you buy from a
bookstore?
Still quite a few of you.
How many of you get them mostly
over the internet?
Okay, not a majority.
Taking out classes,
books you buy for pleasure,
your own decision to buy them,
how many of you are still
buying those in bookstores?
Okay, actually a lot of you.
So, that really,
even, tips the scale in favor
of bookstores,
so that's interesting to me.
I wasn't sure what you would
say.
That suggests that bookstores
are still powerful purveyors of
culture;
they still shape what you think
about and what you read.
It's browsing,
or maybe that you've read about
something, and you go looking
for it, that brings you in to
the bookstore.
Censorship does have a
legal history in this part of
the century.
And so now I want to just give
you a little rundown of that.
So, this is actually a title of
a chapter of a book that I will
be writing on the post-45 novel,
and I'm going to have this as
the last chapter of that book.
The reason for that is that
censorship and what I'm calling
censure--that's the public
outcry against literature,
even not on legal grounds--is a
way for the culture to speak
back to the literary.
So, I spend a lot of time in
this class, and in my teaching
in general, and in my writing,
talking about what books say to
us.
But what do we say back to
those books as a society?
Well, censorship and its
companion, censure,
do a lot of that talking back.
So, there are two sides of
access to literature.
I've just been talking a little
bit about market constraints on
what can be published and read,
and now I'm going to talk a
little bit about legal
constraints.
I'm going to get back to the
market constraints in a little
while.
Since the early twentieth
century, a lot of the legal
constraints on publishing and
distributing literature have
eased.
In the 1870s,
the Comstock laws in the United
States aimed to regulate the use
of the mails for the
dissemination of obscene
materials.
These laws were used in 1914 to
indict Margaret Sanger for
sending information about
contraception across state
lines,
and she had to flee,
and she left the country to
protect herself.
So, just the description of how
contraception worked was a
violation of the Comstock laws;
so of course we're happily out
of that moment.
In 1933, for literature there
was a major decision by Judge
Woolsey declaring that James
Joyce's Ulysses was not
obscene.
Often censorship in literature
would have to do with the import
of literature into the United
States.
So, this is sort of on the same
logic as the Comstock laws.
The Comstock laws regulate the
traveling of obscene literature
across state lines.
Customs regulations regulated
obscenity coming in to the
United States.
Why is obscenity important?
Well, obscenity is largely
recognized by legal scholars as
not being protected by the
Fourteenth Amendment;
it is not protected speech.
So, that's why it was important
for someone who wanted to keep
Ulysses out of American
hands to call it obscene.
Now, it's very interesting to
read what Woolsey says about
Ulysses.
It just shows you how the
learned reading of literature
comes to have a legal impact in
the world.
So, this is Woolsey on Joyce:
Joyce has attempted,
it seems to me,
with astonishing success,
to show how the screen of
consciousness,
with its ever-shifting
kaleidoscopic impressions,
carries, as it were,
on a plastic palimpsest,
not only what is in the focus
of each man's observation of the
actual things about him,
but also on a penumbral zone
residual of past impressions,
some recent and some drawn up
by association,
from the domain of the
subconscious.
He's talking about the
stream-of-consciousness method
of narration in Ulysses.
He shows how each of these
impressions affects the life and
the behavior of the character
which he is describing,
and I'm going to skip down.
He goes on to detail more about
Joyce's technique:
"It is because Joyce has been
loyal to his technique and has
not funked its necessary
implications,
but has honestly attempted to
tell fully what his characters
think about, that he has been
the subject of so many attacks,
and that his purpose has been
so often misunderstood and
misrepresented."
So, here, Woolsey takes a very
serious view of Joyce's artistic
project, and he takes as the
mark of its success what he
calls the loyalty of Joyce to
that project,
of showing exactly what
characters think in their
subconscious associations,
as those rise into
consciousness and into language.
That principle is furthered in
the United States in 1957 with a
case called Roth.
It's Roth v.
United States,
and in this case Woolsey's
approach to the literary is
enshrined in American law,
affirmed as a precedent.
So, according to the Roth case,
something can be judged obscene
only if it meets three
conditions,
and those are these:
The books' descriptions of
nudity or sex must go beyond the
limits of taste established by
community standards.
So that phrase,
"community standards," will
become very important in later
law, and I'll mention how in a
minute.
"It must not appeal to the
interests of the average adult."
So, you have to be really
aberrant in order to meet this
standard;
it can't appeal to the
interests of the average adult.
That's what makes it obscene,
so--I don't know--necrophilia,
maybe that counts.
And lastly--this is the
kicker--it must have no
redeeming social or literary
value whatsoever.
That means if you can prove
just that one,
you're safe.
So, no matter what it is,
even if it is necrophilia,
if you can prove that it has
literary value it cannot be
obscene.
And so this particular
standard comes in to play when
Allen Ginsberg's Howl
goes on trial in--I think
it's 1959--it goes on trial.
Similarly, a customs case and a
case about selling the book:
it was bought at City Lights
bookstore in San Francisco,
and the poor sales clerk was
indicted for selling it,
and also the bookstore was
indicted for importing it.
It had been published in Europe.
All they had to do in that
trial, and it's very funny to
read the transcript,
is to prove that Ginsberg in
Howl was doing anything
remotely resembling literary
work.
And it's very funny to see
people trying to argue that he
was not.
So, it's not enough to say that
he uses the word "cock," for
example, in that poem;
that's not enough.
And the prosecutor tries to
make the case on the basis of
individual words,
and then you see them having
these hilarious conversations
about how individual words work
in metaphors and how they mean
different things.
This standard really saves
literature from any kind of
continuing legal censorship.
But, there are other ways
of producing censorship;
that "community standards"
comes to be a problem in,
for example,
textbook design.
So, there are these huge
markets in public schools in
Florida and Texas and
California,
and so textbook publishers have
to appeal to the community
standards of those huge,
powerful markets,
and that has an impact on
what's available to school
systems all over the country.
So, there is a way that those
community standards,
while in the Roth case they're
redeeming--they help to make the
case against censorship,
against a too-wide definition
of obscenity--it does have an
impact in other ways in the
opposite direction.
Since the 1990s,
in the wake of these changes,
libraries have become the
primary place where legal cases
are based.
So, in 1982 the school board of
Long Island, in Island Trees,
Long Island,
tries to remove,
or actually does remove
Black Boy,
Slaughterhouse 5,
and various other sort of
books of the 1960s,
mainly about politics,
mostly has them removed from
the school library.
And a suit is brought against
that school system for doing
that.
The decision in that case
affirms that even though public
school systems are within their
rights in the context of the
classroom to restrict what is on
the syllabi of their teachers,
that the school library
represents what they call a
"special environment."
The special environment is a
place of voluntary study;
it is a place where the
Fourteenth Amendment cannot be
suspended.
And as they say,
sort of poetically,
students do not leave their
rights at the school door.
And so school libraries can't
be regulated in that way.
But these things come up over
and over, and what's interesting
about that particular case is
that the objection was that
these books were anti-American.
How far have we come since
Black Boy had to be
truncated?
Not that far,
in certain sectors of the
country, in certain ways of
thinking.
Black Boy was cut in
half because it didn't seem like
a good reflection on America.
It's still a problem for some
books in being accepted and
read.
So, I began to talk about
market constraints,
and I want to just say a little
bit more about that and how it
affects the writing of
literature and the publishing,
even before you arrive at the
bookstore.
Traditional publishing has
undergone a huge consolidation
since the 1980s.
So, there are large
multinational corporations that
have bought up publishers.
The one signal example of this
is when Bertelsmann,
a German company,
bought up Pantheon Books.
This is written about in a book.
Now I'm forgetting the name of
it.
It'll come to me.
One of the Pantheon editors led
a revolt when this happened.
It became clear that
Bertelsmann was going to impose
a new standard of profitability
on the lists in Pantheon's
portfolio.
So it used to be in old-time
publishing, sort of mid century
publishing and up to the 1980s,
that the list,
a literature list (and that's
the list of books that any
publisher publishes),
the list should be profitable.
That does not mean that every
single item on that list will be
profitable.
So editors in the old-time mode
could work with writers who they
found to be difficult and
interesting,
path breaking,
unusual, not catering to what
was popular.
They could work with writers
and cultivate them and they knew
that they were taking on a
book--say it's a collection of
short stories;
these are notoriously hard to
sell--they were taking on a book
that was not going to make a
profit.
But then they would also take
on The Joy of Cooking--or
The Joy of Sex,
since it's censorship
day--and they knew that the
profit from a popular book could
help to carry and balance those
less profitable books,
or not-at-all-profitable books,
that they had on the list.
So, there was a management of
lists that could be tilted to
allow different kinds of books
into the public domain.
When publishers were taken
over by multinational
corporations that were very
distant from the interaction
between an editor and a writer,
they looked at the numbers and
they started to demand that
every book have its
profit-and-loss analysis and
that a very strict regulation be
followed in ensuring that all
titles were going to make a
profit.
That's a very different
standard, and it had a huge
impact on what kind of latitude
editors had in working with
writers who they thought might
be a little unusual or not so
marketable.
At the same time,
agents began to have a role in
the publishing business.
In the 1950s,
when editors were encouraging
literary writers directly,
they had a much more
collaborative relationship with
writers.
But as profit became more
important writers needed to turn
to someone else who wasn't going
to pressure them to follow the
market,
and agents came to have a role.
Now, it's interesting.
There is yet a third role that
has just begun to emerge in this
structure, and that is of the
coach,
the writing coach:
so you can now pay big bucks,
if you're a writer,
to have someone who will call
you up every week and say,
"Hey, how's the book going?
Let's talk about your ideas.
Are you writing today?"
It used to be that agents took
that kind of active role.
Well, agents are very busy now,
with their clients selling
movie rights and such things.
Movie rights are where a lot of
the profit in a book sale come
from.
So, agents began to be what the
old-time editor was,
and I think we have yet to see
whether coaches become what
agents used to be in turn.
But, as profitability becomes
more and more of an issue in
selling a book to a publisher,
there is an ever ongoing search
for that person who will be the
ally of the literary in this
process.I've talked about
the consolidation in book
selling,
the rise of the chains,
and I've also talked about
those financial relationships
between book sellers and
publishers,
were space is bought.
They also have incentives that
publishers give,
sometimes give money for
readings to be held at a
bookstore.
So, sometimes those things are
bought also, those kinds of
events, promotional events.
There is, of course,
this whole context of the rise
of the internet,
and all kinds of competition
from the film industry,
other media.
Market constraints are
sometimes paradoxically produced
by that overload that we get
from the internet.
So what that means is the
culture is finding new arbiters.
So, you have this huge volume
of information and cultural
offerings being given to you.
In that welter of information
we all look to some arbiter to
tell us, "How do I sort this
out?"
Nobody has the time to read all
the blogs and decide which one
they're going to read regularly.
So you might get a link from
someone else's page,
someone you are friends with,
someone you admire,
a writer you've seen elsewhere.
You might read certain print
publications and from there
follow them in to the internet,
into cyberspace.
Most books now come with a web
address somewhere on them.
A lot of films do;
most films do.
This is still in a period of
development.
How profit gets connected up
with those arbiters isn't yet
very clear, so companies are
experimenting with paying for
placements,
like when you do the Google
search and there are certain
Google-sponsored links at the
top.
That's like having the space in
the front of your store bought
and paid for.
So you think that you're
getting--or, I think we all know
that those are sponsored links,
now, but at the beginning
people didn't really quite know
that, so it looked like you were
getting-- the product of a
disinterested electronic search,
but in fact you were getting a
promotion.
So the internet experiments
with all kinds of both new and
tried and true ways of using
money to create prominence among
the welter of information.
Then there is another
rising problem in question,
and that is of intellectual
property and access as books are
digitized.
So, I don't know if you have
heard of the Google Book
Project, and also all the
digital libraries initiatives.
There are various ones,
but the Google Book Project is
digitizing with a special
technology.
People think it's probably a
robotic technology--it's kept
secret--for scanning books that
are in the public domain,
and they've made agreements
with lots of university
libraries including Stanford,
Cornell, Michigan,
to digitize all the books that
are beyond the copyright that
are in their collections to make
a huge digital library.
And the dream is that this will
be a sort of bonanza of access.
It'll be searchable.
It'll be--well, maybe--free.
It'll be accessible all over
the world.
So, there is a dream here
that's very noble.
Publishers and writers' groups,
unions, are very worried about
copyright infringement,
because Google has stepped over
the line and is interested in
pushing the envelope into
scanning copyrighted material.
So, what has started to happen
is that individual publishers
have made deals with Google to
let Google digitize their list
for a fee.
But, see, now that money starts
to come into this arrangement,
it starts to look less like
free access and more like an
access that is,
once again, shaped by these
financial considerations.
It's not at all clear how the
nobility of the project and the
financial context are going to
work themselves out,
and it's not at all clear yet
what the general approach of
educational institutions will be
towards this.
Yale has not signed onto this,
for example,
so some universities have;
some haven't.
These are huge,
looming questions that will
impact what we get to see as
literature,
how much access we have among
the vast choices that the
internet makes available to us.
I want to just mention one
more thing, and that's about
internationalization.
One thing that you didn't
probably see at the bookstore is
fiction in translation,
contemporary fiction in
translation, notoriously
impossible to sell.
There is a press called the New
Press that was founded after
some of the Pantheon editors
left and they founded this
nonprofit press.
That is the only kind of
fiction that the New Press
publishes, contemporary fiction
in translation,
because they knew that only a
nonprofit press could publish
this.
It will never sell.
One of the objections to the
Google Book Project is that the
vast majority of its texts are
in English,
and it seems to present an
English-centric vision of the
world's knowledge,
'cause it does have pretensions
to be the repository of the
world's knowledge.
In the reception of
literature there are other
forces, and here's when we start
to move in to the realm of
The Human Stain.
In the 1990s,
there was a very lively and
often acrimonious debate in
academia and among intellectual
commentators about whether
literature was the purveyor of
ideology,
political ideology.
So, the question is,
does literature have a message
that it's trying to tell us?
And one way to think about this
is to think about English 125,
major British poets,
the picture of what the
old-fashioned canon might look
like.
It's all white guys.
I think there might be one
woman that you can put on the
syllabus in the Spring,
a modern poet.
You can probably teach Bishop.
I think people do teach Bishop
in the second term of English
125.
Did those poets represent the
communication of an ideology?
Because a lot of contemporary
fiction became the object of
contention: along with these
very traditional syllabi,
are you going to include Toni
Morrison on your syllabus?
Well, this is no longer
controversial.
She's such an overwhelmingly
powerful author,
at this time,
by the sheer quality of her
work, but early in her career it
would have been a question.
One of the striking things,
of course, about American
fiction in the second half of
the twentieth century,
and into the twenty-first,
is the demographic really does
change.
Writers of color are much more
prominent;
there are many more points of
view present in that canon.
So, is literature sociological?
Does it speak to society,
or is it an aesthetic object,
something that we should
understand as part of the
history of an art form?
Do you have to choose between
these two?
And I cite here what became an
incredibly important book.
It's really a wonderful book by
actually a Yale graduate,
John Guillory.
The title is Cultural
Capital: The Problem of Literary
Canon Formation,
published right at the
height of the culture wars,
of the canon wars.
In it, he argues that in the
mid twentieth century,
literature was a kind of social
elite good,
and that the aesthetic,
if it had an ideology,
it was an ideology of bourgeois
privilege.
So, it wasn't that the content
of particular poems would be
communicating something about an
elite bourgeois ideology,
but rather that the very act of
being in the institution where
you would study such a thing (at
Yale,
in English 125) that was the
repository of the elite power of
these texts.
So it had much more to do with
institutions than it did about
the content of any particular
literary work.
And it makes some very
persuasive readings of canonical
poems that demonstrate the
undecidability of their
ideology,
or the way that they resist how
they've been cast,
how those poems have been cast
by critics.
There are also ways that
novels were received and
complained about that become
part of this picture.
So, we've talked about Black
Boy.
I mentioned how
controversial Woman Warrior
was because of its impurity
as a Chinese text.
Toni Morrison became a real
advocate of writing by women of
color, in particular,
and also as a literary critic
she mounted an argument about
how whiteness functions as a
central part of the traditional
canon of literature.
And she wrote Playing in the
Dark: Whiteness and the Literary
Imagination in 1992,
a very influential text.
Internationally,
we had the phenomenon of Salman
Rushdie's persecution,
the fatwa issued against him by
the Ayatollah Khomeini after the
publication of The Satanic
Verses,
for its depiction of Islam.
That kind of persecution
becomes a feature of this more
internationalized debate about
what is okay to say,
especially about religions,
and then of course we have the
Danish cartoon episode,
with the cartoons of Muhammad
that are now
seemingly…it's resurgent.
There is another question about
a film about Muhammad's life,
I believe it is.
Then there is Roth's work,
and here's where I just want to
meditate for a minute on Roth.
Philip Roth's work has been
defined by these kinds of
objections, that censure that I
was talking about.
He was very widely acclaimed in
1960 when Goodbye,
Columbus won the National
Book Award.
Goodbye, Columbus is a
set of stories mostly about
young Jewish protagonists living
in a Jewish context in Jewish
communities in Newark or in New
York.
It included a story called "The
Conversion of the Jews" in which
a young boy (actually,
well, a little older than young
boy, maybe he's a teenager),
Ozzie Freedman,
becomes extremely agitated
because all his questions to his
family and to his rabbi about
Christianity are dismissed;
he finally comes to be punished
for asking these kinds of
questions.
So, Ozzie stages his revolt by
climbing to the top of the
synagogue roof and threatening
to jump off if his family,
all the assembled students from
his Hebrew school,
and the rabbi,
won't kneel down and pray to
Jesus,
which of course they do because
he's about to jump off.
This story was quite
controversial,
as you might imagine,
so there was a taste of Roth's
vexed relationship to Jewish
community in that story.
So, it was all about how a
hidebound Jewish community was
preventing and circumscribing
the curiosity of a young
American boy,
and it really highlighted
Ozzie's Americanness.
And Roth has always emphasized
that about himself:
He's an American
writer.Like Saul Bellow
before him--Saul Bellow had been
his mentor and teacher for a
brief time at the University of
Chicago--Bellow insisted on
bringing into American
literature the voice and
sensibility of an immigrant
Jewish family.
Bellow was from a Russian
Jewish family that immigrated to
Canada in the early twentieth
century.
Bellow was told he would
neve--because of his heritage,
when he was at the University
of Chicago--he was told he would
never have the ear for language
that would allow him to write
beautifully,
because of his linguistic
background and because he was
Jewish.
Well, Bellow pioneered the way
of bringing in a particularly
Jewish and European notion of
literature and a sensibility
about the body that could enter
American literature and change
it from its either WASPish or
southern genteel quality.
And, certainly,
this was a very powerful
current, and Roth is the
continuation of that current in
American letters.
Roth comes out in 1969 with
Portnoy's Complaint.
Portnoy is quite a novel.
It's really all about
masturbation.
It's about Alex Portnoy jacking
off in the bathroom to every
possible provocative thought he
can have,
and it's told as if to Alex's
psychiatrist in a sort of
ranting, over-the-top style,
very explicit.
This got Roth into big trouble,
partly because Alex lives in a
very tight-knit Jewish family,
and this enters into the whole
story of his obsession with sex.
Irving Howe,
a very prominent Jewish
literary critic,
public intellectual,
wrote a famous essay in 1972
called "Philip Roth
Reconsidered." And he
basically said that the
adulation given to Roth was
entirely inappropriate--he now
saw on reflection,
now that he had read
Portnoy's
Complaint--because Roth had
an unfocused hostility towards
the Jewish community.
This enraged Roth.
That rage fueled huge portions
of his career.
When, in The Human Stain,
Roth has Coleman Silk say,
"All of Western literature
began with a quarrel,
the wrath of Achilles," in a
certain way he is describing his
own origin as a writer.
Now, if you'll go with me:
Do you have just five minutes?
I want to get to one last point.
Roth, in case you haven't
noticed, is a very misogynist
writer.
Did you notice?
Hard to miss that.
Why do I like Roth?
In this context where writers
are taken to task for their
offensiveness on cultural
grounds,
on gender grounds,
on the grounds of
identification,
how can you like someone who
has this major flaw,
who seems to see all women as
sexual objects,
who is unembarrassed about
saying his writing is about a
man's life,
the life of men;
it's not about the life of
women?
So, why do I like Roth?
This has actually baffled me
for years.
Why doesn't it bother me?
There are parts in The Human
Stain that really are quite
amazingly objectionable.
My favorite is the gift of the
molestation.
Do you remember this when they
are talking about Faunia,
and how great she is in bed,
and what she is like at
breakfast afterwards,
and they speculate,
Coleman and Nathan,
that maybe that was the gift of
her having been molested?
Well, molestation is never a
gift.
If there is anything that comes
from living through a hard life,
it is not the gift of the
molestation, but the gift of the
person who survived it.
This is insane.
Why do I still like Roth?
Well, partly it's that,
like no one else,
he can take me into a voice,
seamlessly draw me in.
Some of his ranting voices are
more or less convincing.
Some are more or less
caricatured;
of course the women's are more
caricatured than the men's.
Nevertheless,
he can take me in there,
and the way his sentences work
are really sometimes just
astonishingly beautiful.
There is a part of The Human
Stain that I particularly
like, and you'll get to it as
you finish the novel for Monday,
and that's when he's describing
Coleman and Faunia at
Tanglewood.
So, just think about that when
you read that,
pause for a minute over that.
I think what it is ultimately
is that I'm very moved by two
things in Roth's writing;
that is the meditation on
mortality and what goes along
with that, I think:
the focus on and the dignity of
the body.
There is a very Whitmanian
sense to his understanding of
sex and the body in all its
complexity.
I appreciate that.
I am moved by that sense of the
inaccessibility of the other
person--this is from my lecture
on Monday--the way you always
get the other fellow's life
somehow wrong.
That speaks to me about the
difference between my
consciousness and anyone I
encounter in the world.
That to me is profound and
moving.
It reminds me that,
for all Roth's linguistic
energy and skill as a writer,
there is still that great
divide that language is trying
to cross.
And that's what I appreciate
about literature in general,
that it's that great attempt to
cross that divide.
I can overlook the misogyny for
those things.
Am I like Roth?
Probably not,
but that's why I like him.
I read to see what I'm not,
not to see what I am,
and so Roth's very difference
from me,
his misogyny,
is part of what allows me to
feel that I am entering,
however partially,
however always in a compromised
way, into the consciousness of
another person through that
beautiful,
amazing medium of language.
So, that's why I like Roth,
and I would encourage you to
think about your own responses
to the books that we've read
together,
think about what it means about
you as a reader that you respond
in certain ways.
So we'll pick this up on Monday;
thank you for waiting.